nous terminerons par un sourire les
branquignols sans retour sur la scène de
leurs débuts c'est en effet au théâtre
la bruyère qui dit à 24 ans les
branquignols adapté à la france un style
d'humour hérité des impôts pin et des
marx brothers américains les
branquignols s'appelait à l'époque
robert dhéry et colette brosset
christian duval ex ils n'ont pas changé
vous allez le voir et alain escoubes et
les a retrouvés telles qu'il les avait
connus tels que nous les avions fait
on apprend que ça vient de braque bon
guignole fait pas d'aplomb dans la tête
et c'est charmant c'est merveilleux
d'être fou je valais la barre et on a
marre est trop belle la barre est à la
marie
oh il ya quand même des choses nouvelles
on n'a pas repris des vieilles changer
des choses nouvelles et vieilles choses
c'est nous
nous
l'artiste tout le monde rit et même
chose c'est ça que je trouve sympa je
suis le plus jeune de la troupe en
dehors des d'opter tout je suis plus
jeune c'est pas mal
j'ai fait traiter de branquignols un
jour dans un théâtre
j'ai contacté robert des régies ça peut
plus continuer quand je rentre dans la
troupe
au pouvoir
parce qu'il ya une recette pour devenir
bourguignonne au nord-est je ne suis pas
noir je crois qu'il faudra suffisamment
dreux le sens de l'humour le goût de la
rigolade quan la bêtise on a ri pendant
cinq années on a fait des monstrueuses
blague en coulisses dans la rue les
voisins se plaignaient voulu nous porte
et on a gardé un souvenir exceptionnel
de branquignols c'est un petit peu pour
ça qu'on est là qu'on a essayé de
recommencer
mais j'ai encore paru